well I was running a foreign policy
think-tank in London and what I found on
issue after issue was that China started
popping up on themes which were
completely outside of its traditional
sphere of influence from climate change
to nuclear proliferation to what to do
to solve genocides in different parts of
the world so I decided to go to China
and to try and find out a bit more about
what was going on there and when I went
there I was completely sucked into this
hidden world of think tanks and
universities where there's big debates
going on which one reads very little
about in the West and I was just very
struck that the Beaufort the kind of
size of the intellectual community the
vibrancy of their debate and also the
the stakes involved because the
difference is between for example the
new left and the new right on economic
policy in China a far greater than the
differences between Democrats and
Republicans or the British Labour Party
in a conservative party so it just felt
like there was a lot of state and
there's a lot going on and that we only
get a very imperfect grasp of it if you
read the Western media or even if you
read foreign policy journals well on my
very first visit to China I went to this
think tank called the Chinese Academy of
Social Sciences in Beijing and was just
struck both by the scale of the place
there four thousand researchers there
we're working on a whole series of
different issues but also by the quality
of thinking this this going on they're
not all of these 4,000 people at
world-class thinkers but there is a just
a lively community which is bigger than
any other think-tank community that I've
seen outside of the United States and I
soon found out that the Chinese Academy
of Social Sciences just one out of a
dozen in Beijing alone and each of the
big cities have got these think tanks
but they also have universities as well
so I started going there more often and
I got to know more and more people and
started reading what they were writing
in academic journals and in in
newspapers and looking at some of the
debates that were taking place both in
person also sometimes on the internet
and I suppose I found there were three
parallel debates going on which all have
a lot of significance both the China's
own development but also for the West
one is about what model of capitalism
China embraces and there you have a
group of people who were very
influential in the 1980s who essentially
the into Reaganomics free-market
economics they want the state to
disappear they want China to privatize
everything and embrace the market and
the expense of everything else and
they're being challenged by an
increasingly influential loose grouping
of people called the new left they're
the new left because they're not the old
left that was against the market but
they are left because they care about
inequality and the incredible damage
that's being done to the environment by
China's breakneck economic growth so
that was one kind of debate about the
model of capitalism was going on
secondly there's a debate about what
model of political reform China should
adopt between some people who believe in
incremental democracy they want China to
experiment with elections at a
grassroots level that's already started
with villages is going kind of gradually
higher up within the structure and the
thing which they're most excited about
is well they call intra-party democracy
trying to introduce more democracy
within the Communist Party within the
sort of 70 million Chinese party members
of the Communist Party but on the other
hand there are another group of people
who are increasingly influential or
saying that the last thing China needs
is elections that it needs the rule of
law and it bit any needs a one-party
state that knows what the public wants
so they can give the public what they
want but the way to find out what the
public wants isn't through elections
instead it's by using focus groups
opinion polls public consultations and
what they're developing is what I call
deliberative dictatorship dictatorship
there's much more
Walter to understand to preempt public
opinion and then the third argument
which is maybe the most challenging for
the rest of the world is about about
power and World Order and they're all
Chinese people want China to become a
great power again and to to build its
comprehensive national power but the way
they're doing it is is very interesting
they're taking a lot of cutting-edge
Western ideas like soft power
multilateral integration and an
asymmetric warfare and turning these
things which we in the West associate
with the decline of the nation-state
into ways of making the nation-state
more powerful and there there are two
kind of main groups of people one group
of people that thinks that China needs
to reassure the West about its rise and
to essentially adapt itself to the
existing international system and to
fight for bigger rights within it and
then there are other people who think
that in the long term China needs to
stop appeasing the West and once that
should create a system based in its own
image and I call that debate a battle
between liberal internationalists and
and China's answer to the neocons I call
them the Neo coms because they're trying
to promote the kind of old Maoist idea
of overthrowing the West in it you know
in a new guys and not by directly
attacking the existing structures but by
cleverly using these ideas like soft
power and multilateralism to build
another world around
you